democrats beware more signs a big red
wave is about to sweep them out of
office the associated press setting off
alarm bells with a new report that finds
over one million voters switched to the
republican party last year the change is
happening all across the country and
especially in the suburbs where swing
voters are backing the gop
it's really no wonder with how badly
president biden is screwing things up
just 19 percent of americans say things
are going well
okay jesse um if
we've got so many people who are moving
toward the republican party is the
discussion that we had in the last
segment on roe v versus wade is that
going to level things
off a little bit i think it could chip
away at the wave but the wave is going
to be strong because it's a kitchen
table scenario in in the suburbs there's
a big backlash against the school
districts for smothering the children
with masks and crt and transgender and
then you have gas prices you can zip
around in a subway in the suburbs
everywhere you go you have to fill up
your tank and then everywhere you turn
you see at a strip mall you see 4.99 a
gallon 5 17 a gallon it's like an attack
ad against biden on loop out there then
also if you live in the city and you're
young you what do you eat slice of pizza
you order some chinese food if you're a
young family in the burbs you're going
to the grocery store and dropping 300 a
week interesting remember how much you
used to eat when you were a teenager you
go through like a gallon of milk a day
and also baby formula if you're in the
city you walk 10 blocks you see a
walgreens you see a cvs and a dwayne
reed if you're in the burbs you drive
into cvs no formula you got to get back
in the car another red light you pull in
you got to find parking it's aggravating
but mostly
people love the gossip in the burbs all
right this is not an ideological
situation you know they vote the burbs
for bush then they go to obama then they
go to trump then they go back to biden
it's word of mouth because the women
talk during the school situation the
fathers go to the little league
situation they start gossiping and then
they all get together as couples and
they go out to dinner on saturday night
and after what you talk about netflix
and what the kids are up to you talk
about how inconvenient and expensive
life under joe biden is
it's it's socially toxic to be a biden
voter in the suburbs now
you don't want to identify as a budding
person out there is that what you wrote
down when you borrowed my pen i
underlined a few things
well um you know what this issue with
roe versus wade and how they're trying
to gin everything up greg i mean does
that change things i'm asking the same
question i asked to jesse it is kind of
an interesting thing i mean if if uh i i
i've mentioned how democrats often will
only act if it if there's a political
imperative right that's why crime went
rampant for so long and then they said
oh my god we're losing in this case the
republicans are taking a big risk i
think it is but you've said that it that
it could actually help the republicans
so i don't know sometimes though and
i've said this many times the best way
to win is to let your adversary lose and
i think you know minus the republican
counterweight in all these cities the
democrats have found new and incredible
ways to lose yeah and i mean it's like
the overreach and the abuse people
missed there was another uh
lawsuit in new york that was won by the
republicans that stopped
uh non-citizens from voting i mean you
want overreach that's overreach so i
think the thing is i don't want just a
red wave
i would like a brain wave
you know not just republicans but some a
return of some centrist modern democrats
uh to to bring their party back to
sanity because the best country has two
two parties working together like a mom
and dad they got checks on each other
but the problem is the mom got involved
in some crazy woke cult
and they don't know she doesn't know
where she is she's like she's joined
like the uh like a crazier version of
the manson family and then they and so
we just got to get them back in we got
to get them back in and then have a
really healthy uh uh back and forth
between the republic but without a
single party the democrats have
destroyed their their own party
did the democrats actually leave the
democrat party because they were
disgusted given the one million editions
of the republicans or did they want
something that the republicans were
offering is it was it hate for their
side or do they think they'd like
something better on the republican side
you know i don't know i have not looked
at it i know it was over 43 states it's
the case so i'd love to i didn't get a
chance to dig into it like i wanted but
you find these in these cycles to
jesse's point you'll find par voters
going from one to the other and it
generally bodes well for that party this
poll was taken to your point judge i
think the outset prior to the decisions
on on both guns and and and uh choice
before the courts will be interested i
think that was a premise of purpose of
your question i think the biggest driver
of it though just looking what i was
able to see is what jesse said from the
outset the curricula and what's being
taught in schools and parents
particularly around sex education and
sexual orientation how that is being
taught or proposed being taught i think
has turned a lot of families
particularly in the suburbs
off the democratic party democrats if as
we deal with crime and border and we
want inflation to come down we've got to
get right on those issues as well with
parents all right dana wrap it up so i
was looking at these numbers so a
million uh party switchers for the
republicans that's really good right but
there were 630 000 that went to the
democrats from republican and democrats
so
to me that by if you do the math
i would think that it would be a lot
bigger right and maybe it will be and
so we should check this in a couple of
months to see both parties really need
to put a lot of effort into
voter recruitment but look at the
contrast in the movement so the
republicans just elected the first
mexican-born american in history
that party is getting younger and more
diverse the democrats are looking to see
if hillary clinton's number still works
to see if she could possibly take on
biden and not have him run again in
2024. that was the story of last week
and the democrats have put all of their
eggs in the donald trump is bad basket
but donald trump is not on his name is
not on the ballot in 2022 maybe it will
be in 2024 but it's not in 2022. and the
democrats are offering the working class
and independent voters no reason to go
with them dig into that story a little
bit and just read some of the quotes
from people who made the switch from
democrat to republican
one of the things was the coveted
lockdowns the vaccine mandates and the
obsession with race in all things that
was one of the guys from colorado who
was quoted saying he was a reluctant
party switcher but if you're a
republican figure out a way to hold on
to those people and you might be able to
win some big national elections all
right great point up next another
violent weekend in liberal cities but
far left leaders claim they aren't to
blame everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now